thank you
good morning five gentlemen
of Texas today what's up I'm Zach from
Medicare Studio
press here with the Lord
villain
what's the latest oh my gosh did we
have abandoned out the diesel
just a few eyes
are talking to disabled
so Jack if you could just get in and
play is that mid car mode
for everyone don't know we'll let the
game decide it was mid all right I got a
question for cognito
you might have to go push
it
back into it again
great you know
polishing everything out
of Sergeant Slaughter junkyard
George greats Rocky Johnson yeah
I had to bring it up I saw that
snakeskin
I can win okay that's cold the last time
we don't
care
a lot up
in the game as we
turn fan on wrestle
wrestling
match of characters
there's that
found in the world yeah yeah
spectacle match
and Clarity we're waiting so
I'm surprised it hasn't been done so
exactly
right this is
a kid oh yeah we are I was supposed to
say that we bought it out there put it
out during the main event today
we're gonna get released
thank you
first that right here
right
okay
we hope a wrestle Quest we open Ace of
lab
we open here than you are when you start
bring your own baby
father Lord
I got the time he's away champ right
here
get out of my race
that's it get out get this scum
we'll settle it here
get out of my race